hey youtubers is Charlie and there is
awesome news in the world of Legend of
Korra studio Mir just signed a new deal
with DreamWorks Animation to produce
four new animated shows that's four
different shows not just four seasons of
one show so I'll do a breakdown of what
that deal is what it means for the
future of the avatar series and for the
future of Mike and Bryan I know you guys
all want to see a ton more avatar
content and based on a couple big things
that are happening right now this is
what I think is going to go down bare
minimum they'll release the new Korra
game that they just announced the games
from platinum it's called The Legend of
Korra you can download it from the
PlayStation Network
October 21st and on Xbox the next day on
the 22nd it's a super cool fighting game
that I'm totally going to buy it's only
$15 in the online store like it's
basically a digital download so I might
actually do a giveaway for that the main
actors did the voices for the show so
it's Janet Varney PJ Byrne David
Faustino there's supposed to be a ton of
really awesome Bolin jokes there's even
like a fire ferrets pro-bending mode
that you can unlock when you play
through story mode actually you know
what I think I will do a giveaway I'll
hand out some game codes or something
like that it's a couple of weeks away
it's not going to be till October 21st
in the 20 seconds so why don't we just
say you know make sure you're subscribed
and just leave comments on my Korra
videos and whenever the game gets here
I'll just pick randomly from all the
videos that I've done I should have like
six or seven up by that time speaking of
more Avatar universe content studio Mir
totally just won the lottery
so here's the details of that DreamWorks
deal so they basically signed a 4-year
contract to produce four new animated
series different animated series each
one is going to get 78 episodes just
like Legend of Korra head they're not
going to be avatar based shows there'll
be new IP that DreamWorks and Studio Mir
are developing together the deal itself
is just really interesting from an
economics standpoint you know usually
before this you'd see a major studio
like DreamWorks or Nickelodeon with a
series they try to get animated overseas
so in the past these small animation
studios would be hired as subcontractors
they get like a small fee they'd be way
underpaid and they have no creative
input on the shows that they were
animating studio Mir will be Co
producing these four new shows so
they'll actually get a say in what the
finished product looks like and they'll
have a share in the profits if it makes
a lot of money so it's really good for
them
if you ever listen to any of the
interviews that Mike and Bryan do about
overseas and
or anime in general they talk a lot
about the economics and politics of
animating TV shows so this really is
like winning the lottery for Studio
mirror DreamWorks Animation is badly in
need of a successful TV series right now
most of their films have not made it big
like Pixar Disney frozen for example
just became the highest-grossing
animated film of all time last year so
we all have to give high-fives to studio
Mir for being just absolutely amazing at
their jobs and high-fives to DreamWorks
Animation for recognizing that the big
question is are Mike and Brian going to
be attached to run any of these new
shows the answer right now is we have
absolutely no idea their prime not going
to make any announcements until after
our core book for airs but they do have
a history of developing their own IP so
it's possible that they could have
absolutely nothing to do with this but
they are really good friends with Studio
mirror so it's possible they could
collaborate avatar the original series
was basically how their relationship
with studio Mir started the animation
director on the original avatar series
started studio Mir whenever Mike and
Brian hired him to animate Legend of
Korra in order to meet the schedule that
Korra needed studio Mir basically hired
a bunch of people and became this really
amazing studio that it is right now so
without avatar and break there would be
no studio Mir but that doesn't guarantee
that Mike and Bryan are going to be
involved in any of this DreamWorks stuff
but I at least hope that they come on
board as producers for DreamWorks so the
next big question is is what does this
DreamWorks still mean for the future of
the Avatar series right now Nickelodeon
owns the rights to all things avatar
like I mentioned in my book for
predictions video they will totally keep
producing the comic with Dark Horse and
keep making video games as long as
they're profitable it doesn't get talked
about a lot but you have to remember
there is way more money in gaming than
there is in films and television a movie
earning a billion dollars is crazy it's
amazing but games can make up to the
tens of billions of dollars so there's
going to continue to be more Avatar
universe content but probably not on
television here's a big question for you
guys if they rebooted avatar and even
like three or four years but Mike and
Brian were not attached to it would you
be as excited I don't think that I would
but regardless of whether or not they do
get involved with the new DreamWorks
stuff they're going to continue to do
new shows they actually just took a
break from Korra book for work to do a
podcast with Janet Varney if you're not
familiar with it Janet Varney has her
own podcast called the JV Club you
her guests are actresses and female
personalities from the entertainment
industry so the break pot isn't really
about core it's mostly about Mike and
Brian's lives growing up and some of
their big influences it is really cool
though so I'll add a link in the
description the fact that they recorded
it during a break from working on book 4
makes me wonder what they're up to
they already wrapped most of the voice
work for book 4 so at this point their
pride is doing touch-ups
the next big thing about coming up
though is New York Comic Con they're
basically taking the show to New York
Comic Con doing a panel they're really
good about bringing concept arts so
they're probably going to be teasing
book for stuff I'm not really expecting
anything super spoilery but I will be
doing videos for whatever it is that
they talk about the real big news is
there's a ton more stuff coming from
studio Mir in the near future
possibly some new stuff from Mike and
Brian too they've said for the last
couple of years that they do want to
take a break after book 4 wraps so it's
totally possible that they could just
unplug and take a long vacation I don't
think they'll be announcing any new
projects anytime soon though I think
that was still a little bit of thunder
from korra book 4 since that hasn't
aired yet so once that airs and they're
done promoting it the price are talking
about what's coming next from them I'm
totally going to continue to follow
their work regardless of what they do
they're amazing at building worlds so
hopefully their next series is some sort
of action-adventure anime or at least an
anime series so last big question for
you guys do you want to see Mike and
Brian continue to work with studio Mir
and what do you want those DreamWorks
shows to be I know we're all thinking of
some crazy new adventure anime series
DreamWorks would not have hired a studio
known for anime if they did not want
that kind of look for their show so
that's just something to think about so
even though core is going away Star Wars
rebels is coming that's going to be like
the new animated show I do videos for be
sure to subscribe to get everything
and feel free to just any new anime
series that I should check out but
remember Dave Filoni who does Star Wars
used to work on Avatar The Last
Airbender for Mike and Brian I like the
idea that the Korra universe might have
some small connection to the Star Wars
universe rebels is going to be a Monday
show though so Mondays is going to be
like a Gotham Batman Star Wars rebels
day and since I'm still in the middle of
moving to my new apartment there's not
going to be a Korra Q&A tonight but I
will have a new Doctor Who bonus video
coming tomorrow morning
Episode one just aired last week so if
you're not watching it you still have
plenty of time to jump on but in the
meantime click here for my Korra book 4
predictions and click here to catch
on Doctor Who thank you so much I'll see
you guys tonight high fives